i felt that this was a better message
than just putting up a regular political
sign of somebody's name on it
because this is really what it's all
about it's four years since i last saw
jeff
a steel worker from johnstown
pennsylvania
he's retired now from a factory where
we'd met on the eve of the last election
i haven't put up a political sign like
this in
four years in fact i didn't even put one
up like this four years ago he's more
time these days
for yard signs and more time to reflect
i got one more to go here
this is the pennsylvanian rust belt it's
where american elections are won and
lost
and it's where clinton dramatically lost
back in 2016.
we are putting pennsylvania back to work
[Applause]
i was in the town back then and watched
donald trump win
here and across the state by telling
traditional democrat voters
what they wanted to hear when i'm
president we're going to start
making things again in america
well the four years has flown by plenty
has changed in american politics and i
wonder
if any of those who i met back then have
changed their minds
jeff is the first stop at the local
office of the steel workers union
jeff good to see you let me open this
door up how are you i'm doing well how
are you how do we greet each other in
these covered times like this that's it
you know we kind of
we're pretty serious about this oh
please come in it's good to see you
what donald trump calls for trade would
probably a lifelong democrat he wasn't
swayed by mr trump's promises back in
2016
it's just designed to make some people
who are laid off and not doing so well
in some plants
come on board with him and that's why he
is getting the support
and now well the past four years uh
it's been challenging just the rhetoric
that has come
from the top of our government and uh
everything i thought that was
decent and you don't go there this
president has gone there and he's
created
a lot of divisiveness to the tune that i
never thought i'd see in my lifetime
he did do some things on trade he tried
to drive a pretty hard bargain with
china but what it did
was it put tariffs on our products what
about those steel works
he said i'm going to open up all these
steel mills i'm going to open up the
mines i'm going to bring these jobs back
well today none of those steel mills
opened up there'll be republicans out
there who will say
okay donald trump he may not be the most
refined
of characters but jobs are up
john's town is looking better than it's
done for a while well i say to them
i don't know what you're listening to
trump sell his blow his horn
i have some good republican friends that
between now and next tuesday i don't
really want to run into them
everybody that's going for hillary
please raise your hand
this week four years ago we were at the
johnstown fun run
where intentions were clear anybody
that's going for trump please raise your
hand
on the finish line was financial advisor
eric cabler
i feel that both of them are
knuckleheads however you know
hillary the analogy is that it's an old
dog that you can't teach new tricks
whereas donald is a is a new dog that
hopefully
hopefully we can teach new tricks so he
voted reluctantly for trump last time
this will be very very interesting
how are you again it's very good to see
you again as well
how's things doing well did donald get
taught new tricks
i think from my perspective is that i
think donald did a very good job
uh unfortunately he had to deal with the
impeachment he had to deal with the
coping crisis
and both of those things kind of wrecked
the momentum that we've had
and i'm not just talking about the
economy or the stock market i feel a lot
of people felt
more comfortable uh with his leadership
but what about his rhetoric what about
his divisiveness i said four years ago i
said he's a knucklehead and i'm not
changing my mind four years later
but you still prove him that he's a
knucklehead uh however it's
not just that it's it's his platform of
things that he's for
uh whether it's you know pro-life uh
he's all about
business about the economy getting
people back to work
do you know what i'm struggling to
understand though is is is that
you're happy for a guy who you say is a
knucklehead
to be running the country yeah and again
it's his platform
uh you know he has been uh you know
he's been rude you know you see him in
the debates
uh and you you know he has been
disrespectful to a lot of folks
uh he has a track record of filing for
bankruptcy and
uh all of that type of stuff and so we
wouldn't vote for him to you know be on
the
the school board in our in our local
area
um but because he has the the ability
and the power to be able to
uh make changes in the areas that we
want changes to be made in the country
that's what we're voting for opinions
then are bitterly entrenched
the choice is binary okay let's see i
think i put this one here
and no one we've met here has been moved
over the four years
here we go mark stone sky news
in johnstown pennsylvania